Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
Full House of the Dragon episode 5 video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get them all careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the episode
yet but it was basically like our next Big
Game of Thrones wedding episode now obviously
this is House of the Dragon but it's the Game
of Thrones universe and you cannot have a wedding
in The Game of Thrones Universe without something
bad going on but as far as weddings go this was
actually pretty tame like Robb Stark's wedding
was pretty tame even though he died during the
Red Wedding but if we're talking about Royal
weddings I think Joffrey's purple wedding would
probably be more apropos but we'll start at the
beginning of the episode and go through shot by
shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
as we go along starting with the episode title we
light the way which is a reference to the motto of
house Hightower it references the lighthouse in
Old Town the Old Tower where the seat of their
house actually is which they referenced later
in the episode metaphorically and literally
like lyric strong literally mentions the light
in the lighthouse like do you know what color
it burns when they march to war it burns green
mean as alicent walks into the throne room for
the Wedding Banquet wearing the green dresser
trademark green dress that she's seen wearing
throughout the rest of the timeline both of the
different factions in the dance of the Dragon are
called the blacks in the greens for the colors of
the gowns that the two wear so the whole idea is
that during the episode during the wedding alicent
is basically throwing The Gauntlet at rhaenyra
like she's lit the warfire's house Hightower one
of the other huge things in this episode too is
this is the last episode with the young versions
of the actresses when we get to episode 6 they'll
be like a really big time Jump and we'll have the
older versions I think they said it'd be about 10
years or so goes by like this is meant to be the
older version of aegon I'll do a separate trailer
video for episode six tomorrow they released a
whole bunch of brand new footage I've already
done one so I'll link it below in the description
it has some new footage the other one that they
just released also has even more new footage from
episode 6. as far as I could tell there weren't
any big changes to the opening title scene usually
they only change it when there are new errors when
there are new children born to the people in the
line of succession like you see new lines of blood
come out of the special symbols so because so
many children are born in the next couple of years
between now and episode six and that big time
Jump they'll probably update the opening title
sequence for episode 6. the actual opening scene
is sort of like a small film in and of itself that
takes place up at runestone in the veil on the
coast when we meet Ria Royce for the first time
Classic Game of Thrones introduce a big character
that you've been talking about for a long time
and then just swiftly kill them right off the
show she's been married to Daemon for a while
he was forced to marry her he wasn't really happy
about it and it also sounds like she wasn't very
happy about it either because she spends most of
their conversation just making fun of him and it
seems like she knows about all the things that he
said earlier in the timeline making fun of people
in the veil like yeah you said that we all do it
with sheep up here did your brother kick you out
of court again because this is the second time
he'd been banned so the whole joke here is that
he'd been calling her the bronze talking about her
like she was this terrible person but really she's
fairly attractive she seems pretty normal and she
just really does not like him because he's being
kind of a terrible person the person she meets
with her cousin here Gerald Royce is probably the
person who's going to inherit runestone eventually
they mentioned Lady Jeyne like Daemon says he's
going to go claim runestone oh will she die we
didn't have heirs so all of her Holdings passed
to me on her death the big hill turn at the end
of this episode is meant to be a metaphor for the
way the dance the dragon sort of spins up like
for a brief hot second it seems like rhaenyra
and Daemon are gonna get everything that they
want but then metaphorically at the end of the
episode it's meant to show you how things take a
sharp left turn and it won't wind up ending the
way that they think it will so that's a good way
to explain what's probably going to happen with
Daemon in runestone the Lady Jeyne that Gerald
mentions when he's trying to take him to Tas
accuse him of murdering Rhea Royce is Jane Aaron
the current Lady of house Aaron like the leader of
the veil so anytime you did anything really big
like that like try to claim titles or something
like that you'd have to plead your case with her
and it sounds like she probably won't be a big fan
of Daemon as well either they also had like a Game
of Thrones season 7 Level transition like really
crazy transition going on here too going from that
rock that he kills her with to the fish getting
its head chopped off remind you of the transitions
when they introduce Samwell at the Citadel at the
beginning of season seven with the way that they
were cut between like the grossest scenes possible
but as we see viserys and rhaenyra heading to
high tide on driftmark to propose the marriage to
Corlys Velaryon to arrange how everything is going
to work they introduced brand new Valeryon theme
music for their house which they play a couple
times in the episode later when rhaeny's and later
are riding their dragons back to the red keep and
then later again when they enter the throne room
for the Wedding Banquet and even though viserys
is very sick many times in the episode they remind
you how sick he is like his declining condition
I think the reason why he's sick at Sea here is
just because he's poor at traveling at Sea I
don't think he's getting sick because of his
actual ailment I talked about this in my last
video but the actor paddy considine actually
clarified what his actual sickness is like what is
actually killing him he's actually suffering from
a form of leprosy so it's not some crazy plot with
someone trying to kill him by poisoning the iron
throne and him cutting himself but him cutting
himself hurting himself is making it worse it's
just that there's the actual leprosy that's what's
really killing him we meet Laenor Velaryon with
Joffrey Lonmouth in the yard and they give you a
bigger introduction to Joffrey lawnmouth before
they promptly kill him off during The Wedding
Banquet or Criston Cole kills him off but if
you're not a big book reader basically the whole
idea is they've been lovers for a long time and
the way they talk about it later Corlys Velaryon
his father thinks that it's something that he's
going to get over like oh you know he'll he'll get
married to rhaenyra he'll get over all that stuff
to make a very Game of Thrones reference his
mother rhaenys is more worried about him being
thrown to the Lion's Den with all the drama that's
happening over the battle of the succession like
our sun is going to be in danger you're putting
him in the firing line here when Corlys Velaryon
says his whole aim here is to put a Valeryon on
the iron throne and he's doing that because he
wants Justice he's talking about Justice for his
house because they come from ancient Valyria like
they are very old very powerful house they came
to Westeros before the targaryens did but the
whole idea is that because their family weren't
dragonlords in ancient valyria they had to take
to the sea to earn their living even though
they obviously became one of the wealthiest
families in Westeros the Hawaii isn't the Corlys
Valeryon once a wrecking technician for all of his
family's great Deeds all these many many years so
that's what's going on with him haggling over the
terms of the actual Arrangement like what is the
last name that the children will go by well we'll
call them Velaryon but the minute that their son
takes the Iron Throne he's going to be using the
Targaryen name when viserys says dragons have
ruled the last hundred years they'll rule the
next hundred years the next hundred years puts
them around the point in the timeline when there
were no actual dragons like the last dragon died
and then for a period there were no dragons until
Daenerys were born so he's not wrong it's just
like this was really a sad connotation to what
he's saying like the next hundred years and then
there aren't going to be any dragons for a long
time until a girl comes along and then they'll be
three you also notice that when Corlys Velaryon is
talking about what happened to Daemon and Rhea
Royce there's this hint of doubt in his voice
like he also kind of thinks that Daemon probably
killed her too that'll be interesting because it
seems like Laena Velaryon now who's much older
obviously very headstrong is pursuing a marriage
with Daemon it seems like like Oh no you're single
again why don't we get married now I'll talk about
her a little bit more in a second too they give us
a really quick tour of the high tide Castle we'll
probably see more of it later in the timeline the
reason they called the throne room here in high
tide the hull of nine is because it's named for
the 9 Voyages of Corlys Velaryon the sea snake
there's a very famous story about his voyages that
they were actually going to do a spin-off for at
one point I don't know if they're still doing it
but that's what that's a reference to like all
these great Journeys that he went on and acquired
all these Treasures from them so like some of this
stuff is from the very far east the big mural in
the wall that you may have seen a couple times
is basically meant to tell the history of their
family going back to ancient Valyria the other
big reveal here too is raniera and laner coming
to an agreement quote-unquote like gentlemen's
agreement we will both Let each other do whatever
we feel like doing inside this marriage it's just
a political marriage they make all these metaphors
about the things that they like to eat like you'll
continue eating whatever you like to eat I'll
continue eating whatever I like to eat we know
what's going on here the big surprise here with
Criston Cole and Ranier on the way back is that
he actually does try to get her to run away to
essos with him like just leave it all behind
forget about the Iron Throne all this stuff we'll
go be together over in essos and basically What's
Happening Here is that rhaenyra is asking him to
live without honor and that's his whole thing like
all he ever wanted was to be a knight is a very
Brienne Game of Thrones type of thing later in
the timeline all she ever wanted to do was become
a knight as he says later his honor is basically
all he has to his name and she's kind of traipsing
all over it like you know what just forget about
the rules the rules don't apply to me I'm Gonna Be
The Heir I'll be the queen of the Seven Kingdoms
so it's one of those situations where they want
to show you that there's really no right person
in this whole Dance of the dragons like both the
sides have a lot of terrible people like raniera
is doing a bunch of terrible things the rules
don't apply to me I'm a Targaryen we're above
the rules I'm Gonna Be The Heir which is mostly
what alicent is pissed off at her about for the
way that she seemingly flaunts the rules and
tries to get away with all this stuff and the
way she bold face lied to her about what happened
and kind of throws alicent's honor under the bus
too because the whole idea is that alicent went
to bat for her claiming that she never Never Could
Have Lied like puts her Honor on the line for
rhaenyra we also get the scene with Larys Strong
cozing up with alicent spilling all that tea he's
like Lord Tea spilling tea all over the red keep
basically telling her that ranero was given Moon
Tea not whether or not she took it but that she
was given the moon tea still lots of theories
about who the father of her first child is going
to be his metaphor about the flower from braavos
thriving in the red keep in this foreign territory
is meant to be a metaphor for alicent herself but
also kind of a metaphor to him it even though his
family is already in this position of power what
he's trying to do here is cozy up with her so that
should aegon II take the Iron Throne he be in
a much stronger position so he's mostly doing
this for himself I don't think his father would
have told him to do this because this kind of
leads to the dance of the dragons like alicent
would have continued to back rhaenyra but then
alicent gets Criston Cole to confess to the truth
of what happened and that's when she starts to get
pissed at Rhaenyra like she throws the gauntlet
down wearing the green dress and that's basically
like the beginning of the end for real for their
relationship and when when he talks about his
punishment gelding him torturing him is what
they would normally do to a kingsguard who did
something like that when people become kingsguard
they take a vow of chastity so regardless of who
he slept with he be in really big trouble
no matter what but a King's Guard sworn to
protect the royal family sleeping with a member
of the royal family would really get it so when
he says please take mercy on me by just giving me
a regular death that would be a mercy normally his
punishment would be way way worse they show
you more of viserys's ailment like I said he
has leprosy it's just getting worse and worse and
worse the special vial that they give him is milk
of the poppy to help him sleep quote unquote you
have to imagine that there's going to be like a
10-year time Jump at the beginning of episode six
think about how worse he's going to be by then if
he's this bad now and when he asked Lyonel Strong
how history is going to remember him as a king the
maesters mostly recorded him as being a weak King
whose poor decisions and lack of ability to make
decisions directly cause the dance of the Dragons
so history isn't super kind to him they played
the new house Velaryon theme music again as they
introduce you to rhaney's dragon meleys her dragon
is also referred to as the Red Queen because of
the color of the dragon and we've already seen
laenor's dragon seasmoke back in episode 3. and
the thing with the dragons on house the dragon
they're meant to be 17 total by the end of the
series but we're only going to see about nine
of them this season they said they tried to make
all the dragons look very distinct have different
personalities but both laner and rhaeny's dragons
look similar to the types of dragons that Daenerys
had so a lot of people always ask are daenerys's
dragons descended directly from one of the dragons
that we'll see on house the dragon and that could
be the case The Wedding Banquet happens in the
iron throne room all the great houses enter they
have that funny moment with the Lannisters like
Jason Lannister walks up and kind of gets dissed
by rhaenyra like yeah remember I turned you down
earlier and then he also makes fun of her in
front of viserys we meet Gerald Royce setting
up the drama with Daemon Targaryen later entering
the throne room as well kind of shocking everyone
like haha I bet you didn't think you'd see me here
and I love how loaded this whole wedding scene
is now obviously Game of Thrones weddings make all
the Red Wedding the purple wedding jokes you want
but metaphorically What's Happening Here is the
viserys has all these Grand plans for the future
of the realm that he's set forth but there's all
this really shady stuff going on underneath the
table so to speak like everybody's breaking the
rules in really crazy ways doing really shady
stuff and interrupting the speech about his Grand
plans is alicent basically walking in throwing the
gauntlet metaphorically wearing the green gown as
Larry strong calls out like oh she is definitely
coming for her when he says there'll be seven
days of tournament and feasting to celebrate
the wedding the tournament is actually when the
maesters later in the timeline date the origin
of the actual Dance of the dragons in the blacks
versus the greens like the gallons that the two
of them wore but I think the whole idea is is
the actual Dance of the Dragons won't really
get going to like season two or maybe like the
very end of season one this dwarf character in
the back playing with the band might be a version
of mushroom from the books in the books Fire and
Blood is written from the perspective of an old
maester in the court fool who was called mushroom
who was just always hearing all this gossip
because nobody took him really seriously or a big
threat so they just had looser lips when he was
around so he just wound up hearing way more gossip
and they've kind of given that storyline to Larys
Strong like he is the person with all the tea when
they start their dance this is also a big metaphor
for the dance of the dragons like The Gauntlet is
being thrown between alicent and rhaenyra that's
happening in the background but also raniera
and Lena are both Dragon Riders and they are
dancing so the whole dance is just loaded with
meaning also when she starts dancing with Daemon
their two dragon Riders their two dragons so to
speak so it's like the dance of these dragons
lots of dragons doing a lot of dancing on this
week's episode during the dance she also makes a
reference to the outcome and that's also meant to
be a metaphor for what will eventually happen like
the outcome of the Targaryen Civil War this whole
scene with Gerald Royce and Daemon Targaryen is
meant to be kind of a mirror for the scene with
rhaenyra and Criston Cole where Daemon basically
plays this whole thing like he's above the rules
like how dare you challenge me if someone in
King's Landing tried to slander me they be
forced to pay for their crimes like he threatens
Gerald Royce's life for even suggesting that he
killed his wife so just like rhaenyra felt like
she was above the rules like she wasn't beholden
to all this honor all these rules that Criston
Cole was talking about Daemon's doing the same
thing so just meant to show you the dark side of
their characters like they're both kind of being
terrible people I mentioned Laena Velaryon this is
obviously much older version of the character now
I don't know if she's already started writing her
Dragon I believe she has so hopefully there'll be
a scene in episode 6 where we'll see that but
I think because of the big time Jump she might
be played by an older version of the actress
the whole idea here though is they just want
to show you that she's a little more headstrong
like she actually pursues Daemon probably knows
about all the stuff he's been getting up to too
like she understands she's not completely naive
in all this I think she's supposed to be kind of
rebellious but not quite as bad as Ranier when it
comes to stuff like that like she's got a little
bit of bad girl inside her too then I think the
whole idea with Joffrey lonmouth and criston Cole
is that when he figures out that he's the guy that
Ranier is with any tries to make the deal with
him like let's protect their secrets because it'll
just be better for all of us that's just what
causes Kristin Cole to snap and that's why he
starts the fight and the brawl breaks out even
though we don't see the opening blows like you
only see the actual fight once it's been going
on for a second I think the whole idea is that
he had the conversation with him then walked off
and then eventually Criston Cole just snapped and
went after him really important detail here too
when the fight is breaking out they lose sight
of rhaenyra lyonel strong looks at his son Harwin
strong and gives him the signal to save rhaenyra
there were a couple scenes earlier where you
saw the two of them dancing I think this is just
foreshadowing the idea that he is going to replace
quote-unquote Criston Cole metaphorically and
literally in all senses of the word so everybody
start your strong boys theories we'll talk about
that when I do my next episode six trailer video
because in the episode 6 trailer you actually hear
the older version of alicent making references to
the strong boys from the books the fact that the
father of her children might be someone other than
her husband they also have the whole scene with
Daemon talking to Renee era trying to talk her out
of getting married telling like he's gonna bore
you to death don't do this because he still wants
to marry her because he wants the iron throne and
right now he feels like that's the best way to
do it that's also the reason why he killed his
wife because he wants to get her out of the way
so he can remarry and the King will allow it but
he also wants to marry rhaenyra because she's
the current Heir in funny side Note 2 we post
all the memes but this scene is like the Game of
Thrones version of the distracted boyfriend meme
with rhaenyra Dancing with Harmon strong clocking
Daemon who's talking to Laena Velaryon about them
getting married obviously at the end of the brawl
Criston Cole winds up beating Joffrey Lonmouth to
a bloody pulp he's dead and you have laenor
just crying over his Lover's dead body also
trying to bite back the tears while they Rush
their wedding ceremony like okay let's just do
this right now get it out of the way so if it
wasn't clear they are married now like the deed
has been done but the meaning shouldn't be lost
on you that viserys collapses immediately after
they finish the wedding ceremony like the clock
is ticking King is going to die any moment now
and I love the way they juxtaposed Criston Cole in
the godswood trying to kill himself until alicent
saves him I think the whole idea like to make
the metaphor she lights the way for him like
to make a metaphor to their house motto she helps
him regain his honor slowly but they don't start
a relationship or anything like that like it's
not quite so spicy as that her whole thing is
that she's very prim and proper she follows the
rules that's also part of the reason why she's
mad at rhaenyra because rhaenyra lied to her
like they were meant to be real close friends
and she lied to her also they may have had some
kind of relationship between the two of them as
the actresses imply but also because raniera
is flaunting the rules in a way that alicent
doesn't think that she should be able to so it's
not like alicent is going to turn around and start
a relationship with Criston Cole or anything like
that that's not what's going on between the two of
them but it was actually pretty short episode for
House of the Dragon so far mostly episodes have
been a little bit longer than an hour this
felt a little bit shorter than that just a
real quick Game of Thrones shotgun wedding if you
spotted any other Easter eggs or references in the
episode that I didn't mention in the video just
write them Below in the comments in my episode 6
trailer video we'll post tomorrow they have a
whole bunch of brand new footage so I'll talk
about what's happening with that big time Jump
and who all those new actors are playing my full
episode 6 video will post next week after they
release it too make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click here
for my house the Dragon episode 6 trailer video
I'll update the link as soon as I post that and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!